con la ayuda de la gráfica de la función
f calcula los siguientes límites y aquí
nos muestran la gráfica de nuestra
función que tiene esencialmente son
varias líneas rectas unidas o bueno y
aquí con este salto y nos piden calcular
estos dos límites comenzamos por este de
aquí arriba el límite cuando x tiende a
3 de fx menos f de 3 / x menos 3 así que
nos fijamos en el 3 porque ya que
estamos en el 3,3 y en este caso f vale
1 verdad en 3 así que lo que vamos a
hacer es calcular la pendiente
tomándonos x digamos cercanos x cercanos
a cada una de bueno x cercanos a 3
verdad nos podemos ir aproximando por la
derecha por la izquierda eso de ahí no
hay ningún problema el detalle es que
nos vamos a ir aproximando ahora bien
nosotros estamos parados digamos sobre
una recta si estamos suficientemente
cerca del 3 está
sobre la misma recta esto es una recta
así que nada más tenemos que calcular la
pendiente de esta recta y eso es muy
sencillo porque digamos por cada
cuadrito que yo avanzo hacia la derecha
yo bajo dos cuadritos ok entonces
podemos ver que la pendiente aquí es
menos dos por cada uno hacia la derecha
bajo dos ok entonces la pendiente en
este caso es menos 2 aquí tenemos que
nuestra pendiente es menos 2 muy bien
ahora vamos a ver qué pasa con el otro
límite vamos a ver qué pasa con el
límite cuando h tiende a 0 de efe de 8
más h
- efe de 8 / h así que nos fijamos en el
incluso marcado tengo el punto ocho coma
efe evaluado en ocho muy bien y lo que
yo voy a hacer es tomarme h es muy
pequeñas y me voy a ir aproximando otra
vez esta es la fórmula de una pendiente
verdad tomó 8 + h por ejemplo si h es
negativo pues andaré por aquí o quizás
por acá verdad y me voy a ir aproximando
hacia el 8 luego esta es la fórmula de
la pendiente sin embargo hay que notar
que si yo tomara puntos a la derecha
aquí hay algo extraño verdad pero no
pasa nada porque me está diciendo que me
tome h es que se aproximan a 0 pero no
arbitrariamente sino que sólo se
aproximen por el lado izquierdo es decir
cuando cuando nos tomamos h negativas
así que sólo vamos a irnos tomando
tomando estos estos puntos muy bien
entonces por ejemplo me puedo tomar este
este de aquí esto es 8 + h
efe de 8 + h muy bien
esto es este punto ahora como calculo la
piel la pendiente otra vez pues aquí
resulta que por cada dos que yo avance
ok por cada dos que yo avance en la
dirección horizontal yo subo dos o bien
por cada uno que avanzo yo subo uno así
que la pendiente no es otra cosa más que
uno muy bien es decir porque si por cada
uno que avanzó a la derecha subo uno
pues la pendiente es 1 ok
así que notemos que si nos aproximamos
por la derecha es decir hagamos un breve
experimento si nos vamos aproximando por
la derecha la pendiente parece que va
haciendo cosas raras
de hecho hace cosas tan raras que aquí
vamos a tener una pendiente infinita